do the right thing I hope so I hope so
because if Mike Pence does the right
thing we win the election all vice
president Pence has to do is send it
back to the states to re-certify
and we become president and you are the
happiest people
Mike Pence is going to have to come
through for us and if he doesn't
that will be a sad day for our country
Mike Pence I hope you're going to stand
up for the good of our Constitution and
for the good of our country and if
you're not I'm going to be very
disappointed in you I will tell you
right now
[Applause]
we need backup
and the United States Senate
[Applause]
people
yeah we're out of here we're going to
give Brian a warning I'm gonna try and
get compliance but this is now
offensively Orion
49 hours declaring it a riot
increasing five to 50p by the cow police
one advisor trying to breach and get to
the Capitol
42. we're about five minutes we're
trying to make our way through all this
[Applause]
let's go
I think we have a free to the capital
Bridge of the capitol for the afternoon
The Advisory requesting additional
resources on the east side as they've
broken into that window and they're
trying to kick it in
without objection the chair declares the
host in recess pursuant to Clause 12b of
rule one
my kids didn't have the courage to do
what should have been done to protect
ourselves
[Applause]
we can't hold this we're gonna get too
many people here look at this point
oh my God
[Applause]
thank you
we need our area for these housing
members they're all walking over now
through the tunnels
of the counter
support
[Music]
okay
stand back
[Applause]
start moving their resources inside we
regard to M4 officers first
[Applause]
I'm happy
h2o8 with four members the doors
barricade there's people who under the
hallways outside we Have No Way Out
in fact officers still remaining on the
house floor in the on the third floor to
use the subway something else it's time
to evacuate so we can secure the members
on the other side coffee
what's up
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign